I'm Mark Oppenheimer. I'm the director
of the Yale Journalism Initiative, and we're
delighted
to sponsor this event along with the
Office of Sustainability of Yale University.
Holly Parker, and Erin Sturgis-Pascale and I have--
I was about to say we worked hard, but actually we haven't worked terribly hard--
sufficiently hard to bring together
two people who
are remarkable presences is the
debates about
parking, traffic,
sustainability,
the environment,
and so forth.
Donald Shoups is going to speak first,
and then we're going to go right into Tom
Vanderbilt's presentation, and we'd ask that you reserve
all of your comments and questions for the
end, and they've both been incredibly gracious
in suggesting that we allow ample time for
comments and questions
at the end.
As a preparatory matter, let me just say that
we
one always wonders of putting together an
event
at Yale College
what's the demand for this event and
how small a room would it have to be so that
it seems crowded,
and
I'm just
delighted to say that we guessed right, and
that in fact there
is
real curiosity about the questions that
they ask
and about the research
that they do,
and
Shoups was a graduate of Yale College and
also got his doctorate in economics here.
He has since taught at the University of Michigan
in Ann Arbor
and also at the University of California in
Los Angeles where for some time he has served as
professor.
As many of you probably know, he's the author
of "The High Cost of Free Parking",
and perhaps most
prestigiously he has been referred
to by
no less an authority than the Wall Street
Journal
as a parking rock star.
I think he's the only parking rock star
in the room anyway.
And he will be followed by Tom Vanderbilt who
is
a graduate of the University of Wisconsin and is
a long time
freelance journalist for
publications like the New York Times Magazine,
Slate,
Wired,
and even Gourmet.
He is the author of "Traffic",
which has won him the
status of--he's been called
a traffic guru,
and so
along with the parking rock star we have the traffic
guru,
and between the two of them we think they're going to
present a very
exciting
evening of discussion of
traffic, parking, and our
green future, so please make sure that your
mobile phones are off at least set to some sort of
very quiet
setting,
and please join me
in welcoming first
professor Donald Shoups.
Well, thank you for inviting me to speak to
you tonight. It's an honor to be here speaking
in the classroom where I can remember being a
student.
For those of you
who are students or can remember their days
as students, I think
you may have figured out that
college professors come in two types.
I don't mean the men and the women or the liberals
and the conservatives;
I mean the dogs of the cats.
The dogs run around in packs.
They bark a lot, and each one tries to become the
top dog,
but the cats are solitary.
They like to mark territories
as their own so that other cats will stay out.
And among professors of transportation planning,
the dogs chase after moving cars,
or they ride around in cars with their
heads hanging out the window, excited by speed,
but cats do not like riding around in cars,
and they never hang their heads out the window.
Cats
instead inspect all of the parked cars,
and they mark the tires.
They also enjoy sleeping on the hood of a newly
parked car where the engine is still warm.
Cars are parked ninety five percent of the
time,
so while dogs chase after the cars the five
percent of the time that they're moving,
I felt I could learn something about the
ninety five percent of the time that the cars
are parked.
Tom Vanderbilt and I divided it up. He gets
the five percent of the time the cars are
moving, and
I get the other ninety five percent of the
time.
But I think that parking is very important
for many reasons.
Say, in a group this large, several of you were probably
even conceived in a parked car.
I was surprised to learn that I've been called
a parking rock star, which of course is not a
real rock star, but still I'm thinking of
changing my name to Shoup Dog.
It's also an honor for somebody from California, especially
Los Angeles, to be
asked to talk about
transportation planning
in Connecticut or New England
because
here's the view that
most initiatives seem to have
of California.
And it is true that we've paved a lot over with parking lots,
and the easterners think that we've
even chopped down all the redwood trees
to build gas stations.
There are some, but
I think
like California, too much of
urban America looks like this picture of
silicon valley.
There's a light rail line in the lower
right hand corner of this picture, but you
couldn't call it transitory and a development,
and we tend to ignore this asphalt blight in
our life especially when we're parked free on it as
all of these cars are at two o'clock on a weekday
afternoon.
But parking is free to us only in our role
as motorists
of course.
Just because we don't pay for parking doesn't
mean the costs cease to exist
We pay for all this parking dearly in every other
aspect of our life as a homeowner as employees,
as a taxpayer,
as a citizen.
Silicon valley in California are not the only
places where parking dominates the landscape.
Here is of a picture of New Haven
There's a lot of parking in that--
Let's see, I think I have two pictures of
New Haven.
Let's see, here's one.
Yes, where is this? I think you can see there's
Temple Street garage in the picture,
and the connector, which was built when I was a student,
which really seems to be more of a divider.
Here's another view of the
part of the city.
There's an awful lot of parking in New Haven.
If more parking were the solution to the
urban problems,
New Haven would be a very prosperous city.
There's a parking garage that was
built when I was a student.
It's quite a wonderful piece of sculpture,
and it works very well as a garage, but I
don't think we should tell ourselves that more
parking is going to
of solve many of our problems.
It was built of course as part of an urban
renewal project. Large parts of New Haven were
torn down to provide the space
for this, and
the shopping center that I can remember being
built is already been torn down right next
to this building.
So I'd like to start with some
background. I think for both Tom's and my talk.
Our automobiles by themselves consume an eighth of the
world's oil supply every day.
And we import two-thirds of this oil.
And we're paying for it with borrowed money.
We have more vehicles than cars.
And it
doesn't seem like it when you're a student or
a faculty member at Yale,
but American drivers park free for ninety
nine percent at the end of all of their trips.
And I don't think this is sustainable.
And the question is are we going to have a hard landing
or can we figure a way to solve some
of our problems. I think we can.
I think we've made
two big mistakes, and one
is to keep curb parking
free or cheap
and to require lots of off-street parking.
Here's the parking requirements of the
city of New Haven,
which are quite modest compared to most
cities' parking requirements.
They look very scientific. Somebody must know
how many parking spaces
a vocational trader business school needs.
Or a "game room" as defined in section 42.2.
I think if you
asked any of these planners where those numbers
could come from,
none of them could explain a single
one of these numbers.
It looks scientific,
but it isn't.
I think that the
pretense to knowledge of us planners,
that we can tell you how many parking spaces
must be supplied before anything can be built
or any business can be opened,
that's done a lot of harm.
I think it's
really a great planning disaster, which Peter Hall
defines as something that costs a lot
of money and has gone seriously wrong.
I think that all of those parking skews all of our
travel choices toward the car as the natural
way to get where you want to go. It caused
a lot of sprawl; it spreads buildings apart
to provide room for
the parking between them.
A lot of the building's design is degraded
by having to provide all the parking, and
that makes housing more expensive because
it has to include the cost of the parking, and
this is something that even
many planners don't understand. It makes
it very difficult to reuse older buildings
because if you want to
open a
restaurant in the former shoe store,
the planners will say, "Well, where's the required
parking?"
And if you don't have the required parking,
you can't open the restaurant.
So older buildings can't fulfill the role
that they could
in the city.
It limits home ownership. It's very difficult to
convert apartment buildings
where people rent into condominiums
that they could own.
It damages the urban economy. I think it's
done that in New Haven.
You don't have to
explain the fact that it harms the environment.
So some cities are solving this problem
in a new way. It's to get the price of parking
right. Here's
some of the reforms that are going on. It's
to charge the right price for parking.
By that I mean
the lowest price you can charge and have
one or two vacant spaces on every block.
That's about an eighty five percent occupancy
rate. So the parking is well used,
it's almost full, but is readily available.
Anybody driving down any street in your city
can always see one or two open spaces
ready to park in front of any store or restaurant
so you can go in.
And cities have made this politically popular
by returning the meter revenue to the neighborhoods
that generated it. If you put in parking meters,
and charge
performance prices for parking, you'll get the
revenue.
And that has  this tended to make it very popular
with the merchants
and the land owners and the residents who
benefit from the added public services in
their neighborhoods.
Once you do that,
you could remove or or all produce at least
the minimum parking requirements
because you won't have to, nobody can
say there's not enough parking because wherever
you go you'll see plenty of parking.
And I think this freedom from parking requirements
will mean you can use any building for any
business that's legal.
Now here's an example of what they're doing
in San Francisco. They're starting this policy,
and this is just an example of the prices
that they expect to charge.
The prices will be the lowest price
they can charge in any hour and still have one or two
vacant spaces on every block. So it can
be different in different times of day,
it can be different in
different parts of the city,
it can be higher at the second hour.
Once you say that we have a principle
the we understand, this is the price that we
want, the price that will lead to
convenient parking
and well used parking, that's how we're going
to set the price. We're not going to let
just inertia set prices.
And because they have a twenty million
dollar grant from the federal government
to institute this. They have a lot of money for graphic artists, and
they're important for anything you want to do.
Here's an example of what they
say is what's wrong with the city. That some blocks
have
all the spaces occupied, and other blocks
have some vacancies.
So the idea is you raise the price on the
top block and you lower it on the bottom block,
and you get something like this.
Isn't that simple?
Some people
think that charging these market prices for parking
are an enormous social
upheaval compared-- like the reformation or
prohibition--
some enormous change in the way we do
live our lives.
But look what a small change
can achieve what is a good result.
So it's very easy to legislate this. Here's
the exact
ordinance language of one city
in northern California
is that the city council ceased trying
to set the price for
every parking space and micromanaging,
saying it should be a dollar an hour within the
two hours.
They didn't want a policy to do, what they
did is set the policy
of what they want the parking
supply to do,
to be readily available
but well used.
They establish it. They give the
transportation authority
the responsibility to move
the price up and down. And the council members
can just look out the window and see if they've
done their job.
If the spaces are half empty then the price
is too high.
If the spacebar all full, the price is too low.
And they made this popular
by
returning the money to the
meter zone.
So that all the affected parties,
the stakeholders as we call them now, supported it.
It passed the city council unanimously.
They also removed the time limits on curb parking
because if the prices are going to create vacancies,
you don't need to force turnover.
You shouldn't have a low price and force people
of spaces at the end of twenty four minutes,
thirty minutes, or an hour.
You should let people park as long as
they're willing to pay because the curb park
is more expensive than the off street
parking, and anybody who wants to park for a long time
naturally gravitates to the off street parking.
So it's as simple as the Goldilocks principle
of parking prices. We all learn this as
children. No bed should be too
soft or too firm, and parking prices shouldn't
be too high or too low.
And I think
one of the problems with our existing system
of having low prices
is that it creates cruising for curb parking,
which is driving around the block, we've all
done it
many times hunting for a curb parking space.
Here's a situation you could face in
almost any city where the
curb parking is cheaper the off street parking.
How long would you be willing to drive around
hunting for a curb space rather than pay to park
off street? We all face this problem
and because of this problem
there's an awful lot of
cruising for curb parking. And here's
the survey,
a sort of summary of surveys.
The first one is in 1927, appropriately
in Detroit,
finding
a fifth to a third of all the cars on the
street
were cruising for curb parking.
The most recent ones were in New York with a very
clever
technique
of
interviewing drivers who were stopped at
the traffic lights and asking them if they
were hunting for curb parking.
And you can see here
spot twenty eight percent and another was
forty five percent of the cars were cruising
for parking.
That is an environmental and a
transportation crime.
Just think, the wasted fuel, the air pollution,
creating congestion,
and this is sort of what looks like. This was
a study done in Chicago in 1939
where they stationed, well I'm sure they were
undergraduates at a lot of corners,
and they noted
every car the past every intersection,
wrote down the license plate and the exact time
so they could recreate the path of travel of
every car.
Some people were obsessed with parking around one block,
and some people were open to new experiences,
try something different.
And this leads to
a lot of very
risky behavior.
People will, they're only focused on trying
to get a parking space.
They ignore bicyclists, they
ignore pedestrians.
I've seen it happen, a car sees across a vacancy
on the other side of the
street will make u-turn in the middle
of the street, which is very dangerous. Here's some
grainy footage I got and researched
in Westwood.
I was able to interview the driver
afterwards, and she says she knows it's
cheaper to park at
the curb, and she does whatever it takes to get
a curb parking space.
Well, here is the results that we found
in Westwood village. We studied
this for year,
and in this little fifteen block area there
were almost a million miles of vehicle
travel hunting for underpriced curb parking.
And after you get to this little fifteen
area,
they're a million miles a year of traffic
hunting for underpriced curb parking.
We found that on average there were two cars
circling every block, and it took only three
minutes to find a space, but they're so
many people who park in a year,
it all adds up. That's equal to
four trips to the moon
in a fifteen block area is happening all
over the Earth.
All over the Earth.
Some people will say it's un-American
to charge
for curb parking even if it does,
if it would help the environment,
but I think it's very American to charge people
for what they use.
Here's a picture of
homeowners around the LA
Coliseum during the Olympics in 1984,
and it happens during every event
at the Coliseum, that the residents
park their own cars on the street and rent
out their driveways to
take it over.
Some people think it's too difficult to do what
I'm saying. They have the idea that all
parking meters are like the original parking meters
in 1935 that
you put your money in the slot, and you turn the lever,
you hope to get back before your time runs out.
But then when they were invented they were
condemned as being a a devilish combination
of an alarm clock and a slot machine.
You take your risk.
But that's because most Americans don't know
all the progress that's happened everywhere
else on Earth. We're now the lagging behind the rest
of the Earth in meter technology.
Here's a parking meter of the sort that
some cities have put in. Maybe New Haven has them.
This is on the UCLA campus,
designed to look like a retro parking meter.
It doesn't even accept coins. It accepts
credit cards and dollar bills.
It doesn't tell you what the price is until you
push a button,
any button, and then it tells you what the price is
at that time.
And here it is, it doesn't even tell you what the
price per hour is Of course it's three dollars for the
first hour and four dollars for the second
hour.
Well, let's see. Is it too high? Is it
asking too much for college students to
pay?
Well I say you can't tell whether the price is
right until you look at the results.
So I think some of you are
aware that professors have a lot of spare
time,
and I set up my camera across from the
meter and looked at eight parking spaces
controlled by this meter. See, there's the
meter and there's somebody paying.
And I think that one out of eight spaces should
be vacant. Around that.
But let's look what happened during the hour.
You can see the shadows move as the time goes by.
Some people leave,
some people don't.
Sometimes there were all the spaces full,
but there were quickly
vacancies, sometimes two vacancies.
Once three vacancies,
then they filled up.
So this is what happened at the
end of the hour.
And I think that
this show to me that was the right price
in that location at that time.
And I don't see how anybody could argue it's
too high
or it's too low.
What principle would you use to say that
price was wrong?
It would be different at a different
time,
but that's what I'm arguing for.
Now I think that it's easy enough to do,
that we have a choice. Our first future is just to
change nothing,
but I think inertia is the
driver of most curb parking policies and curb
parking prices in the United States.
Keep curb parking free or cheap,
require ample off-street parking.
And we'll live in this world with this appalling
ad where people are told to buy a cheap car.
Low income people are told to buy a cheap
car rather than ride on the bus.
We'll buy lots of cars and big cars and park them
for free. Here's the front of the Kodak Theatre on Hollywood
Boulevard.
We'll need lots of roads for these cars. Here's
in New Brunswick, Maryland.
We'll need lots of freeways,
and we'll have plenty of congestion.
With people on their way to their parked car, to their
free parking.
But we do have a
possibility for a second future, which I think
is far better.
We could charge performance-based prices
for curb parking.
We could use the revenue to
prepare sidewalks, to plant street trees, to put
wires underground,
to improve neighborhoods, to pay for public
infrastructure.
And then we can remove off-street parking requirements.
Here's the kind of world,
some people say this is he's recommending.
But let me conclude right where I began in Silicon Valley.
Suppose you bought into this policy,
and
certainly
I'm kind of an evangelist as you can tell,
trying to convince people that were doing
the wrong thing, and we should do the right thing.
Suppose they bought my ideas, remove the parking
requirements on this land,
which is now committed to parking. You
couldn't build anything else on it because it wouldn't
have the required parking.
That that building is as big as it can be
given that parking lot.
Suppose you say we remove the parking requirements
and allow them to build on this lot.
Now I picked buildings from the University of London
because they look nice. I was speaking to the
Congress for New Urbanism, and they like these
buildings,
and they must have just
been cleaned,
but we wouldn't get that in California,
so I just took more pedestrian apartment buildings
in Los Angeles. Suppose you tried it.
And remember everybody in Silicon Valley complains
that the traffic congestion is terrible,
the cost of housing is so high, the commutes are so long.
This would address all of those problems.
And remember, all of those cars, or many of those
cars in that lot are imported from California.
You cannot important apartment houses, so if
you were an electrician or a plumber
or a dry wall builder or a roofer, you'd
probably think this was a great idea.
If you were a worker at Cisco Systems, you could
walk across the parking lot
to get to work.
If that worked out, if they made much more
money by using that land for housing rather
than for their employees,
job adjacent housing,
than for free parking,
they could just keep on doing it, and it could
quickly become to look like a city.
As you walked along that sidewalk, the curb
parking wouldn't be free,
but there would be street trees, and there would
be buildings, it would have ground floor retailers.
What would we do with all the parking garages that
we won't need, all the Temple Street garages?
Here's one in Holland. They found a wonderful
use for it. I think the Yale students could
do this too.
I think that
these reforms are needed
unless General Motors succeeds with its ace
in the hole, has really got a
great idea.
If it succeeds, I think everybody at Yale will
buy one of these cars.
Here's the ad for it.
I think that would be
great for Yale students.
And faculty and staff!
Well I think planners should always conclude
with a quote from Jane Jacobs,
that we aren't rich
because of what we have done.
We are a prosperous nation because of what we've
inherited,
and it's up to us
to make it
to continue this prosperity, and I think our
current parking policies
are driving us in the wrong directions,
and I think that
we have a President who likes to quote
Abraham Lincoln. There's nobody better to quote in
United States' history. I think our case
is new, and
I think that
maybe ten years ago it would have
been unthinkable to recommend market prices
for curb parking,
and planners rejected makers as sort of
an alien ideology.
But I think now we're more willing to look at
prices as the way to solve our
problems.